[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد ليله معاكم زين العابدين
توفيق وبين ما نتحدث الان تتفاعلوا احداث
وتقع اخرى نبدا من برلين
اعلنت السلطات القيامه اجهزه الامن
الالمانيه بحمله واسعه النطاق ضد اعضاء
فيما تعرفوا بحركه مواطنيه الرايخ
بدنا كيف تعطيني هذه الصور مباشره اليوم
مفوض الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان تحدث عن
تقرير يوثق مقتل مئات الاوكرانيين خلال
السيطره القوات الروسيه على محيط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بتهمه التخطيط للاستيلاء بالقوه على
السلطه في المانيا حمله دهن واعتقال في
صفوف التيار اقصى اليمين السلطات تقول ان
المجتبى فيهم كانوا يعتزمون تنفيذها هجمات
وانشاء جيش موازن
زيارتي وفد روسيه لانقر لبحث الخيارات
الشماليه سوريا موسكوت واي دسيناف الحوار
على اساس اتفاق اضن الذي يمنحه انقره حق
التدخل في سوريا لحمايه امنها
واشنطن تؤكد التزامها بدعم الشركائها
وترفض العمليه البريه التركيه المرتقبه
وقائد ما تعرفوا بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
يرفض تفكيك قواته او الانسحاب لصالح قوات
النظام السوري
[موسيقى]
بوتين يقولون مدى العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا قد يكون طويله ويحمل
كيف مسؤوليه نشوب الحرب
على ان فرص السلامي منعدمه حاليا
النخبه في جهاز مكافحه الارهاب واستهدفت
اعضاء في حركه مواطن الرايخ قال للدعاء
الالماني انهم كانوا يخططون اقتحام
البرلمان والاستلاء على السلطه وتنفيذ
هجمات المسلحه
استطلاع يا رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في نظركم ما
طبيعه الجهات التي استهدفتها الشرطه
الالمانيه
41% قالوا انها تجسيد لموجه جديده من
التطرف وقال
27% انها خلايا نائمه ذات توجهات مبيته
بينما رجحت 32% انها جهات مرتبطه بحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا
هذا السؤال يبقى مطروحا في منصات من
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز الكيو ار الظاهر الان على الشاشه
لقاءنا في المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه الثانيه عشر وخمس دقائق بتوقيت
مكه المكرمه وتابعون الجوله الرياضيه
اليوميه يوميات المونديال التي ترصد
بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر
2000 و220
[موسيقى]
الى المانيا اذا اعتقلت السلطات الالمانيه
25 شخصا بينهم جنود سابقون وسليل لاحدى
العائلات الملكيه الالمانيه السابقه هو
الامير هنريش الثالث عشر ينتمون جميعا
لجماعه من اقصى اليمين تسمي نفسها حركه
مواطن الرايخ وذلك بتهمه الاعداد لاسقاط
الدوله الالمانيه الحكومه الالمانيه وصفت
العمليه الامنيه التي جرت لاعتقالي اعضاء
الحركه بانها عمليه ناجحه ودليل على ان
المانيا في حالهم مرسل الجزيره افاد
باعتقال برلمانيه سابقه قياديه في حزب
البديل الالماني بينما اعلنت الشرطه
الايطاليه اعتقال ضابط سابق في الجيش
الالماني في ايطاليا على علاقه باقص
اليمين
هذا هو قال المدعي العام 1000درالي في
ولايه اشتوت كارت بيتر فرانك ان الجناح
العسكريه التابعه للمجموعه الارهابيه كان
يرمي لبناء جيش الموازن وللقيام باعمال
الارهابيه داخل المانيا
واشار الى ان نحو ثلاثه الاف شرطي الماني
شاركوا في عمليه الدهم
كانت هناك مجموعه من الاشخاص يهدفون الى
التحرك والقيام ببعض الاعمال ومنها السعي
الى بناء نظام دوله جديد و لتلك المجموعه
ذراع عسكريه تهدف الى بناء جيش الماني
جديد من مستويات عده وبعض افراد تلك ذراع
العسكريه عمل سابقا في الجيش الالماني
اعضاء المجموعه الارهابيه حسب معلومتنا
كانوا يسعون للقيام باعمال ارهابيه حتى
داخل البرلمان وخلال عمليه الدعم شارك نحو
ثلاثه الاف شرطي من كل اختصاصات ومكاتب
التحقيقات في مختلف الولايات الالمانيه
فعاليته من هذا وقالت وزيره الداخليه
الالمانيه نانسي فايزر ان مجموعه مواطن
الرايخ تتشكل من جناحين احدهما مدني ويمثل
قياده التنظيم ويتبعه جناح عسكري كان يسعى
لاقامه جيش موازن واضافت الوزيره
الالمانيه ان اعضاء التنظيم تجمعهم
معاهدات الديمقراطيه والدوله ووحده الشعب
الالماني
التي تم الكشف عنها تعتنق ايديولوجيا
انقلابيه
ولن يكون بامكاننا الجسم بشان مستوى تقدم
مخططها الانقلاب ضد الدوله الا بعد تحقيق
المعمر يمكننا الان قولوا ان منتسبي هذه
المجموعه توحدهم كراهيه الديمقراطيه
والدوله ووحده الشعب الالماني
وقد اعلنت وزاره الداخليه الالمانيه ان
القوات الامن تبحث عن اي علاقه محتمله
لروسيا بالمخطط الذي كشف عنه اليوم مشيره
الى ان كل الانشطه الروسيه تحت مراقبه
السلطات الامنيه هذا وقال الكلام ان
العمليه الامنيه ضد حركه مواطن الرايخ هي
شان داخلي الماني بحث واضاف الكرملين لانه
لا يمكن الحديث عن اي تدخل روسي في
التحضيري للانقلاب في المانيا كما نفت
السفاره الروسيه في برلين اي علاقه مع ما
وصفتها بالجماعات الارهابيه واكدت ان
المكاتب الدبلوماسيه والقنصليه الروسيه في
المانيا لا تقيموا اتصالاتهم مع الممثل
جماعات الارهابيه او كيانات غير شرعيه
اخرى
هذه العمليه الامنيه التي نفذتها المانيا
اليوم واستهدفت حركه مواطن الرايخ اعتقل
خلالها عدد من المشتبه في تخطيطهم لاسقاط
النظام السياسي في المانيا وصلت الضوء على
حيثيه ما حدث وعلى هذه الحركه وفكره
وانتشارها وطبيعه منتسبيها في هذا العرض
واسعه نفذها نحو ثلاثه الاف من افراد
واحده النخبه في جهاز مكافحه الارهاب عبر
11 ولايه المانيه الهدف المعلن وفق
الادعاء الالماني اعطاء في حركه مواطن
الرايه كانوا يخططون لاقتحام البرلمان
والاستلاء على السلطه وتنفيذ هجمات
المسلحه على مؤسسات تشريعيه اخرى نقطه
انطلاق تحقيقات كانت صله بين اعضاء الحركه
واعضاء مجموعه وطنيون المتحدون الذين
اعتقلوا في ابريل الماضي على خلفيه
التخطيط لاختطاف وزير الصحه الالماني
تاسست حركته مواطن الرايخ في ثمانيات
القرن الماضي وبلغ عدد مؤيدها عام 2020
نحو 19000 وفقا لمسؤولي الاستخبارات
الالمانيه حدد نحو 950 من بينهم على انهم
من اقصى اليمين ولد ما لا يقل عن 1000
منهم ترخيص اسلحه الناريه
يتركز اعضاء الحركه في الجزء الجنوبي
والشرقي من المانيا وبدات الاستخبارات
الداخليه بتتبعهم بعد واقعه قتل عضو منتمي
للحركه لضابط الالماني عام 2016
وتم الكشف عن انتشار منتمينا للحركه في
اوساط الشرطه الالمانيه مما دفع سلطات
الست ولايات لفتح تحقيقه مع افراد في
شرطتها بتهمه الارتباط بحركه يمنيه متطرفه
على حركتهم اسماء عديده منها مواطن
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه وحكومه الرايخ
والاشخاص الطبيعيون واعضاءها ليعترفون
بدوله الالمانيه الحديثه ولا بقوانينها
ويمتنعون عن دفع الضرائب والمخصصات
الاجتماعيه ويسر لنا على ان الامبراطوريه
الالمانيه لا تزال قائمه حسب البيانات فان
الهيئه المركزيه للحركه يطلق عليها اسم
المجلس وشكدت على غرار مجلس الوزراء في
الحكومه النظاميه اي تتضمن وزاره
العدل والخارجيه والصحه وفق المدعي العام
الالماني اعضاء المجلس يجتمعون بانتظام
منذ نوفمبر 20 الثاني 2021 واسسوا تراعد
عسكريه تهدف الى القضاء على دوله القانون
والديمقراطيه على مستوى البلديات
والمقاطعات وقبل اربعه اشهر حذرت
المخابرات الالمانيه من ان البلاد ينتظرها
مواصفات الغضب بسبب تنام المد اليمني
المتطررف واستغلاله حاله الغضب العامه
بسبب تبعات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ودعم
برلين
للقارئ انه لا يمكن الحديث عن اي تدخل
الروسي في تحضير الانقلاب في المانيا
معتبرا العمليه الامنيه ضد حركه مواطن
الرايخ شئنا داخليا المانيا
انا من برلين
فورست كبير الباحثين في مركز بوليس 180
للدراسات الجيو سياسيه ومن وصله
والبروفسير توري يورغو مديره مركز ابحاث
التطرف في جامعه اوسلو وابدا بضيفي من
برلين
يعني ما الذي يمكن قراءته في حجم العمليه
الالمانيه لمواجهه هذه هذه الجماعه ثلاثه
الاف من النخبه الالمانيه تشارك في هذه
العمليه 25 معتقلا اعتقالات في المانيا
واعتقالات في ايطاليا ما الذي يمكن قراءته
من حجم هذه العمليه
والله
مؤشر على انها
اليه مقاومه الارهاب تعمل بشكل جيد
وكذلك الحكومه الجديده
بعنايه
تم القاء القبض عليهم وهم مؤشر على ان
المجموعه ليست كبيره جدا
وليست منتشره عبر المجتمع كثير من هؤلاء
كانوا متقاعدين
ورجال شرطه
قدماء لم كثير منهم لما
ليسوا صغار السن اذا ليس هناك لا يبدو ان
هناك خطرا همم مباشره
لكنه مباشره على ان جهاز الامن يعمل بشكل
جيد وبحذر همم شديد
ولا يستطيع ان يخاطر ان تسير الامور بشكل
سيء حقيقه انه ذلك رجال شرطه سابقون
برلمانيون السابقون الى اي مدى يمثل مؤثرا
على ان هذا الفكر يعني ليس محدودا ليس
محدودا في مجموعه صغيره
[موسيقى]
يدل على ان هؤلاء الناس من المؤسسات
الامنيه
همم كانوا
هم
الحكومه الجديده ايضا تركز على المسائل
الامنيه
وزاره الداخليه تقول انها تنظر
بشكل
دقيق على ال من كانوا يعملون في الحكومه
اصبح الان يحاولون ان يعملوا ضد الحكومه
ضد الدستور اذا هذا مؤشر على ان هذه
المقاربه ناجحه
برلين
مركز كبير الباحثين في مركز بوليس 180
للدراسات الجنسيه واتوجه بالسؤال الى ضيفه
من اوسلو البروفيسر
الخبير مدير مركز ابحاث التطرف في جامعه
اوصل هذه المجموعه ظهرت في الثمانينات
ليست والده اليوم
ظهر لها ظهرت لها اعمال عنيفه في 2016 ثم
تم القبض عليها الان ما الذي يميزها عن
مجموعات اليمين الاخرى
الحركه
الامبراطوريه
واكثر هي هي فكره او عقيده اكثر منها
مجموعه
وبعض الناس لهم افكار مشتركه
وبعضهم ممثلون معروفون
ما حدث في 2016
ان بعض الافراد
اعلنوا ان انهم دوله مستقله
ويرفضون ان يكون لهم اي صله بالشرطه او
بالسلوتات واا كان هناك
مصادمات واا تم اطلاق النار وبعض واحد قتل
وبعضهم همم تعرضوا للاصابه ما رايناه في
العمليه الاخيره مختلف
همم مجموعه اكبر من الناس
للقيام بعمليه لاستلاء على الدوله وهذا
مستوى اخر هل هذا الفكر يعني له قبول في
وسط المجتمع الالماني الفكر العوده الى
الامجاد القديمه
وفكره مظلوميه الحربين العالميه الاولى
والعالميه الثانيه قال له قبول في وسط
المجتمع على الماني بحيث يمكن ان يكون
لهذه المجموعه حوائض شعبيه
نوع مين
حركه صغيره جدا
بالرغم من ان ربهم لهم دايمون يصلح عددهم
الى 20,000 فهي تظل مجموعه صغيره
[موسيقى]
الامير العمليه العسكريه التركيه في شمال
سوريا ومع استمرار القصف في تركيا
في شماليه سوريا 9 موسكو ايجاد حل المنطقه
من اجل ما تقول انه ضمانه وحده التراب
الروسي اما واشنطن الداعم الرئيسي
للمسلحين الاكراد في سوريا فجدد مسؤولها
رفضهم لاي تحرك عسكري تركيا بري محتمل
ساخنه هي الحدود السوريه التركيه وتقبل كل
الاحتمالات خصوصا في مناطق سيطره ما يعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا
مع استمرار الضربات التركيه لمواقع تلك
القوات تواصل اطراف دوليه تحركها لايجاد
حلول
من عمليه عسكريه تضمن فيها امن حدودها
الجنوبيه كما تقول
الموقف الابرز كان من موسكو التي تحدث
وزير خارجيتها ان عزمي بلاده منع اي
اعتداءات على وحده اراضي سوريا وهو تصريح
يشير الى ما يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
التي تراها اطراف اقليميه ومحليه انها ذات
مشروع انفصالي يرمي الى خلق من طاقه
يحكمها اكراد سوريا رغم ان تلك القوات لم
تعلن صراحه عن مشروع تنفصل فيه لمنطقه عن
الاراضي السوريه وان تمتعت تلك المنطقه
بما يسمى غاره ذاتيه عاد الافراط الى
الواجهه اتفاق ايضا المبرمه بين تركيا
وسوريا عام 98 واتفاق يمنح تركيا حق
مطارده منتصفهم بالارهابيين داخل اراضي
سوريا بعمق خمسه كيلومترات كما يمنحها حق
اتخاذ ما تراه مناسبا لضمان امنها القومي
في الاتفاق ارضيه مناسبه لاستئناف الحوار
بين تركيا والنظام السوري لحل قضيه امن
الحدود بين البلدين مع اخذ ماخاوي في
تركيا بعين الاعتبار
قد يحمل خطاب الافراد على انه طرح من
زاويه جديده لمقترح قدمته موسكو سابقا بان
تحل قوات النظام السوري محل ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه عند الحدود المشتركه مع
تركيا بالنظر الى رفض تلك القوات المتكرر
للمقترح الروسي لتجنب العمليه البريه
التركيه المحتمله يقول قائد ما يسمى قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه انها انتزعت السيطره
على المنطقه بعد معارك ضد تنظيم الدوله
وان تفكيكها غير وارد حتى مع الوصول الى
حل سياسي في سوريا واضح تماما تركيزه
موسكو على دوري مؤثر في مشهد شمال شرق
سوريا مع ارسالها وفدا الى انقره يبحث
خيارات هذا الملف
اما واشنطن الداعم الرئيسي لما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه فقد جدد منسق لاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس امنها القومي جون
كيربي جدد رفض بلاده لاي عمل عسكري شمال
شرق سوريا وعلى الارض اعلن التحالف الدولي
لقتال تنظيم الدوله والذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده التزامه بدعم من سماهم شركاءه في
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لايجاد منطقه امنه
ومستقره فضلا عن استئناف في تفسير دوريات
امنيه مشتركه مع تلك القوات
فكيف سيكون وضع شمالي شرقي سوريا خصوصا ان
تركيا منحت مهله زمنيه لم يحدد اجلها لبدء
عملها العسكريه البري الرامي لطرد
المسلحين الاكراد
هذا ونقل موقع اكسيس عن مصدر الامريكيين
قوله ان احدى ضربات الجويه التي نفذتها
تركيا الاسبوع الماضي اصابت هدفا يبعد اقل
من نصف كيلو متر عن موقعي ان تتمركز فيه
قوتنا امريكيه ونقل الموقع وعن مصدرين
امريكيين اخرين لان مدير المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه
وليامز ابلغ نظيره التركي ان الضربه
الجويه تعرضت قوات امريكيه للخطر وحث على
عدم القيام بغزوه بريه كما ابلغ بانز
نظيره التركي معارضته للغارات الجويه على
الاكراد في شمال سوريا حذر من انها قد
تعرض جنود امريكيين للخطر هناك وكشف
المصدر ان الضربه الجويه التي تحدث عنها
المصريون الامريكيون نفذتها الاستخبارات
التركيه باستخدام طائرات مسيره
معنى من انقره اوزجان تيكيت الكاتب الصحفي
التركي ومن واشنطن ستيفن هايدمان البحث في
مركزي سياسه الشرق الاوسط بمعهد بروكينغ
ابدا
التحديث الامريكي كيف ستتلقاه انقره هذا
التحذير من جانب المخابرات الامريكيه
لتركيا بالغز والبري وايضا بقصف مناطق تقع
قرب القوات الامريكيه
الزينه تركي
انا
حاطط الولايات المتحده
بانها
عمليه
المتحده فهمت في البدايه هذه الرساله
القادمه من تركيا
وكانت قبل اسبوع وقالت انهما بدا يقومون
بدوريات المشتركه على الحدود
التركيه في داخل سوريا ولكن كما راينا
تطورات الولايات المتحده بدات
او تستانف دورياتها مع
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ايجاز هير واعتقد هنا ان تركيا مره اخرى
سوف تتواصلوا مع الولايات المتحده
وتنسق معها
والتفادي اي حوادث
والعسكريون الاتراك والامريكيون يعملون عن
كسبوا وينسقون حتى لا يكون هناك حادث في
حال قيام الهجوم البريه
واشنطن ما موقف واشنطن المتوقع او المتصور
من هذا الطرح الروسي ما طرحه لافروف
بان تتولى هذه المراكز الحدوديه مع تركيا
قوات النظام السوري عوضا عن قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وفقا الاتفاقيه اضنه الموقع
عام 98
قالوا انهم
يتعاملون مع العسكريين
النظام السوري
وهذا الاقتراح من روسيا
وتم تحقيقه
ويبدو ان له معنا اخر همم غير الذي قصده
السيده غروف
وهذا يشير الى مدى تعقيد الذي اصبحت به
هذه العمليه
وروسيا
معنيه والولايات المتحده معنيه
واشنطن همم استئنافات هذه الدوريات
وهو ربما بمثابه التحذير ل- همم انقره حول
ما يمكن ان يحدث في حاله حدثت هذه العمليه
وهناك مؤشرات حول موقف طيب
الامريكي يعني الولايات المتحده قالت عبر
وزير الخارجيه وغيرهم وزير الدفاع انه
هنالك مخاوف تركيه مشروعه ما الذي فعلته
واشنطن للتعامل مع المخاوف التركيه
المشروع
فيديو فيديو
[موسيقى]
ان لها الحق في الدفاع عن امنها ولكن
التفاهم حول كيفيه القيام بذلك او انه هل
هناك حاجه الى مثل هذه العمليه لتحقيق
الامن هنا يبدو الاختلاف في وجهات النظر
مره اخرى
العمليات العسكريه قد لا تؤدي الى الفوائد
التي تتطلع الى تحقيقها اا تركيا وينبغي
ان تفكر جيدا في تابعات هذه العمليه وان
تفهم ان حمله عسكريه ربما تكون طويله
وستكون سيكون من الصعب على تركيا الخروج
منها
الاكراد لا لا يتوقف ولا هنالك بوادر على
انه سيتوقف اسجان تيكيت فيما يتعلق
بجدو هذه العمليه يتحدث ضيفنا من واشنط
دون ان قد تكون غير مجديه وطويله الامد
ولا تحقق الهدف المرجوم منه وايضا اتفاق
ايضا الذي طرحه وزير التكلم عنه وزير
الخارجيه الروسي وهو لا يعطي لتركيا اكثر
من خمسه كيلومترات داخل الاراضي السوريه
فما الذي تريد تركيا تحقيقه بعمليه
ارجو ماشي
جدا ووقع
تركيا وسوريه وهو يعطي الحق لتركيا اذا
كان هناك تهديد ارهابيون ضد تركيا علم
الحدود السوريه
وكما تعرفون غدا
تقول ان تركيا وسوريا وسوريا يمكنها ان
تنسقى مع تركيا
اذا قامت احداها بهجمات
جبارين روسيا تلعب دورا مهما وتركيا
وروسيا تحاول ان تتوسط بين سوريا وتركيا
واعتقد
يمكن ان نرى البردين
يتواصلان
بطريقه عسكريه وادي دبلوماسيه
وربما يمكننا ان نرى بعض الخطوات المفاجئه
من قبل البلدين
لي
مقاومته لي التصدي
لمنظمات الكرديه
هو الولايات المتحده التي
كيس
بويست تفعله في حال قامت هذه البلدان
بالاتفاق على سلامه اراضي
التركيه والسوريه كما تعرفون روسيا ايضا
واشنطن السيد ستيفن هايدمان اذا حدث هذا
الاتفاق بين النظام السوري وبين تركيا
ومعه همم ومعهم روسيه همم على محاربه هذه
تنظيمات الكرديه ما موقف الولايات المتحده
ما الذي سيحدث لاسيما انه همم هذه
الاعتراف جميعا ايضا قادر على محاربه
تنظيم الدوله وهو العنوان الرئيسي التي
تضعه واشنطن كسب لدعممها للاكرام
الجيش
انا اختلف مع زميلي من تركيا
هناك حدود
للدبلوماسيه
الروسيه بل فشلها
ومحاوله تدخل بين
وسيطه بين الحكومتين
التركي
الحكومه التركيه عبرت عن استعدادها لتعامل
والتواصل مع نظام الاسد ولكن الاسد رفض
ذلك
لذلك لا اعتقد بان انا لا ينبغي ان نعتبر
ذلك النجاحا للدبلوماسيه الروسيه
وهي ادت الى طريق مسدود اذا من الساعه
بانتوقع ان يكون هناك اتفاق بين النظامين
التركي والسوري شكرا جزيلا من واشنطن
ستيفن من مدير مركز الباحث في مركز سياسه
الشرق الاوسط بمعهد بروكينز واشكر ضيفنا
من انقره الكاتب الصحفي التركيه
[موسيقى]
بين مد وجزر تتواصلوا حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا في شهرها العاشر بينما يعود
الحديث عن حواري محتمر لنهائي السرعه
وعدده القيمه استعدادها للحوار اذا كان
هناك مقترح جاد بينما قال لمين العام فرصه
للسلام في اوكرانيا في الوقت الراهن
واشنطن بدورها قالت انا يعني تشجيعا لها
على ضرب الاراضي الروسي
في غير اتجاه التصعيد تتحرك سياسيا مواقف
فرقاء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا دون
انجازات الميدانيه ملموسه تتوالى يوميات
القصف المتبادل في نقاط التماس فيما يشبه
مروحه للمكان منذ لاستعاده الاوكرانيه
لخرسون الوضع الميداني القائم رغم احتدام
المعارك رافقته تصريحات سياسيه متفاوته
بشان التسويه يقول الروس انه مستعدون لها
في حال وجود مقترح جدي ويستدعي وزير
الخارجيه سيرجي خطاب ما قبل الحرب بشان
مخاوف بلاده من توسع النيت شقه
وخصوصا الولايات المتحده كدوله تقود الحلف
يرفضون دون خجل كما تذكرون الاعتراف بانها
وعدد كل من كربه
بعدم التوسع شرقا رغم وجود ادله كثيره
تؤكد انهم يكذبون على الطرف المقابل جاء
نفي امين عام حلف شمال الاطلسي يونس
ستورتنبرغ وجود فرص للسلام في اوكرانيا
حاليا
المسؤولون في واشنطن يواصلون من جهتهم
تاكيد دعم اوكرانيا في الحرب ولكن مع
اشارات واضحه على الصبغه الدفاعيه لهذا
الدعم
الاوكرانيين من تنفيذ ضربات داخل روسيا
لكن المهم هو ان نفهم ما يعانيه
الاوكرانيون يوميا جراء العدوان الروسي
المستمر
الامريكي النسبي للدعم الذي يفهم من كلام
بينكن وزنه لايت اوستن وزير الدفاع في نفس
المؤتمر الصحفي حين نفى منع بلاده
لاوكرانيا من تطوير قدرتها الذاتيه علشان
ضربات بعيده المدى اي في العمق الروسي
كانما لسان حالي واشنطن لحليفتها كيف لن
نفعلها نحن ولكني فعلوها ان شئتم وهي قد
تبدو رساله للجانب الروسي اكثر من كونها
مجرد ابراء ذمه امام الحليف الاوكراني لم
تحجب تلك المواقف السياسيه غبار المعارك
التي ما زالت دائره على الارض يقول الجيش
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تواصل قصفها
على مقاطعات الجنوب والشرق حيث تركز
هجومها على باخ موت التي نفذت فيها خلال
الساعات الماضيه عشرات الضربات الجويه
والهجمات الصاروخيه على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه مقابله تنفيذ الجانب الاوكراني
غارات على مواقع تمركز روسيا واسقاط مسيره
روسيه في عدد من خطوط التماس من جانبها
تحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن اسقاط
طائرات الاوكرانيه مسيره في لوجان واسقاط
طائره الاوكرانيه من طراز سوخي 24 فوق
ارتي موفقه بمقاطعه دونتستك وتدمير عشرات
صواريخ الانطرازي هايمرز في كريفا روج وسط
اوكرانيا
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي
متروكوليبا في تغريده الله على تويتر ان
حزمه عقوبه التي اقترحها الاتحاد الاوروبي
تتضمن بعض العناصر المهمه التي اكلتها
اوكرانيا منذ فتره طويله بما في ذلك
العقوبات ضد المزيد من البنوك الروسيه
وايقافه بث المزيد من قنوات الدعايه
الروسيه واضاف وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
انه ارسل رساله الى فروض الشون السياسيه
والامنيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي اقترح فيها
فرض عقوبه صارمه على انتاج الصواريخ
الروسيه اي شيء يستخدم لاطلاق الصواريخ
قاتله على اوكرانيا واكد انه يجب حرمان
روسيا تماما من اي قدره على ضرب البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا
هذا وقال الرئيس الروسيب الذيمر بوتن ان
خطر نشوب حرب النوويه اخذ في التزايد لكن
روسيا تعتبر لاسلحه تنويه اداه للرد فقط
اثر تعرضها لهجوم اضاف بوتن ان موسكو
لديها الكثير من الاسلحه وهي الاكثر تطورا
لكنها لا تريد التلويح بها وتعتبرها اداه
ردع وقال انما تصفها روسيا بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا يمكن ان تصبح
طويله واضاف الرئيس الروسيه ان الغرب
يستخدم عقيده حقوق الانسان لتدمير سياده
الدول واكد ان روسيا تعتمد بالدرجه الاولى
على الوسائل السلميه لكنها مستعده للدفاع
عن نفسها بكل الوسائل المتاحه
معنى من اصله وجلاندي سن استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه ايست والخبير في شؤون
اوراسيا اهلا وسهلا بك
يعني قبل ايام تحدثت مديره الاستخبارات
الوطنيه الامريكيه عن ان الحرب هسه تشهد
وتيره بطيئه في الاشهر القادمه ثم هنالك
حديث روسيا الان عن الاستعداد
لمناقشه اي مقترح جاد لسه السلام هل نحن
امام همم بالفعل مقترحات جاده لانهاء هذه
الحرب بالطرق السلبيه
درس درس
متزادا
[موسيقى]
يعتقد انه يمكن يوم الانتصار فلا يكون
هناك حظ اقل للتواصل الى توافق لكن اذا
كان طرفان
يخسران فهناك اهتمام بالمفاوضات
اييي شهور الشتاء الان
تدخل
وروسيا جنت 300,000 من الجنود الجدد
للقيام بهجوم
ويقومون بحرب بالوكاله اذا
نرى من جانب حلف الناتو ان هناك رغبه في
الدخول في مفاوضات
الجنرال مارك ميلس قال مؤخرا ان اوكرانيا
تمكنت من تحقيق ما تريده من اجل البدء في
المفاوضات والرئيس يود ان يجلس مع بوتين
ومكرون ايضا يقول
ان هذه الحرب ينبغي ان يوضع حدا لها بطرق
سلميه والامين العامه سترالتون برج يقول
ان ان هذه الحرب لا يمكن حلها
بالطرق العسكريه وان دبلوماسيه ضروريه اذا
الحرب لا تسير في اتجاه النيتو لذلك اتوقع
ان يكون هناك اهتمام اكثر
بالمفاوضات الاهلي
وكيف سيترجم هذا الاهتمام هل سيترجم في
شكل ضغوط على على كياب
اكتب بيس مباشر
مع روسيا وعلى الغربي ان يمارس بعد الضغوط
على اوكرانيا ربما هذه الضغوط موجوده ولكن
متابعه الحال هذا تحذير من حلف الناتو هي
تحارب باسلحه الفنيته وكذلك الاستخبارات
ولو قرر ان يسحب بعضا من دعمه فان
اوكرانيا لن تصمت كثيرا وعندما تقول
امريكا ان الحرب ينبغي ان تنتهي في ينبغي
ان تستمع اوكرانيا
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
ضيفنا من اوسلو
بريطانيا
لتعزيز امن الطاقه وخفض الاسعار وذكر
بيانو مشترك صدر عن رئيس الوزراء بريطاني
ريشي سوناك والرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن ان
البلدين سيقودين العمل على تقليل الاعتماد
العالمي على صادرات الطاقه الروسيه
واستقرار اسواق الطاقه وتنشيط التعاوني في
مجالات كفاءه الطاقه والطاقه النوويه
والمتجدده
وسنفذ المبادره وفقا البيان فريق عمل
مشترك جديد بقياده كباره المسؤولين في
الحكومه البريطانيه والبيت الابيض
وتعليقا على الشبكه الامريكيه البريطانيه
الجديده في مجال الطاقه قال رئيس الوزراء
بريطاني ريشي سوناك عند لندن وواشنطن
تقفان معا في وجه الرئيس
يعملان لتقليل الاعتماد العالمي على
امدادات الطاقه الروسيه
نقلت وكاله الاعلام الروسيه عن المتحدث
باسم الكربلاند متر بيسكوف قوله ان روسيا
تبحثوا خيارات مختلفه بشان كيفيه الرد على
فرد سقف لسعر نفطها ودخل حيز التنفيذ يوم
الاثنين قراره وتحديد السقف لسعر النفط
الروسيه المنقولي بحرا عن عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل وتقول دول مجموعه السبع واستراليا
عند القرار محاوله للحد من قدره روسيا على
تمويل حربها على اوكرانيا
الى تونس رئيس غرفه الغرفه الوطنيه لاصحاب
المخابز في تونس محمد بوعنان اكد ان
الغرفه قررت وقفه الاضراب الذي بدات
تنفيذه الاربعه وتعليقه الى العاشر من
الشهر المقبل وذلك اثر تلقي وعود حكوميه
بمعالجه الملفات العالقه ونقلت وكاله
الانباء التونسيه عن بوعنان قوله ان
الاضراب الذي تم بدءه الاربعاء نجح بنسبه
95% وان المخابز العصريه عملت من جانبها
على توفير ماده الخبز وياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي تشهد فيه الاسواق التونسيه غيابه عدد
من المواد الاستهلاكيه اضافتها الى ارتفاع
اسعار السلع اخرى عاديدا
في فقره المتابعه ستكون لنا وقفه مع ازمه
الخبز في تونس من حيث سياقها وافاقها
وتاثيراتها على المواطن التونسيه البسيط
[موسيقى]
نقلت وكاله الانباء السعوديه عن الرئيس
الصيني الشيشان قوله وانه سيبحث خلال
زيارته التي بداها الاربعاء للسعوديه
العلاقات الثنائيه والقضايا الدوليه
والاقليميه ذات الاهتمام المشترك واضاف
الرئيس الصيني وانه يتطلع الى حضور القمه
الصينيه العربيه الاولى والقمه الاولى
للصين ومجلس التعاون الخليجي للعمل مع
القاده على الارتقائي بالعلاقات الصينيه
العربيه والعلاقات الصينيه الخليجيه الى
مستوى جديد ومن جهه ثانيه وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان مملكه
تطلعه للعمل مع الصين ودول الخليج ودول
العربيه من خلال القمم الثلاث على تكثيف
التعاون في المجالات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والتنميه تحقيقه للتطلعات هذه
الدول والشعوبها نحو الوزير المزيد من
الامن والاستقرار والرفاه والازدهاري
هذا واقله الخارجيه الصينيه ان القمه التي
ستعقد في الرياض بين الصين ودول المجلس
التعاون الخليجي ستدفع العلاقات بين
الجانبين الى مستوى جديد اوضحت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه مع اونينج ان
الرئيس الصيني الشجن سيتبادل وجهات النظر
مع قرات المجلس بشان القضايا ذاتي
الاهتمام المجتمع
بشكل معمق مع قاده الدول المشاركه بشان
العلاقه مع الصين والقضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك نؤمن وان هذه القمه ستعزز صداقه
الصينيه الخليجيه وستثمر العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين الصين ودول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وستدفع العلاقه بين الجانبين الى
مستوى جديد
حتى جون كيلي المنسق السياسي في البعثه
الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده جميع الاطراف
السودانيه على الانخراط في حوار بحسنيه
وانشا حكومه الانتقاليه مدنيه ودعكري الى
اتخاذ خطوات لخلق بيئه ملائمه للمفاوضه
الى خلق بيئه اكثر ملائمه للمفاوضات من
خلال اطلاق سراح المعتقلين السياسيين ووقف
العنف ضد المتظاهرين والغاء القرارات
الاداريه الاخيره التي تقود نقابه
المحامين السودانيين والمنظمات المهنيه
الاخرى تدين الولايات المتحده تصرفات
المفسدين داخل السودان وخارجه في محاوله
لتقييد الفضاء السياسي وتقويض استقرار
السودان
البيت الابيض عقد اجتماعا الاسبوع الماضي
لبحثه امكانيه عدم التعامل مع وزراء وزراء
متطرفين في الحكومه الاستراليه الجديده
وبحسب الموقع فان السفير الامريكيه لدى
اسرائيل توم نايت حتى الاداره الامريكيه
على عدم التسرع في النقد العلني او في
اتخاذ اجراءات ضد الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده كما حدث السفير اداره البايرن على
اتباع نهج اكثر دقه وحذرا تجاهها حكومه
لتنياهو المنتظره وعدم اتخاذ موقف المتشدد
منها واكد المسؤولون الذين نقل عنهم موقع
اكسيس انه لم تتخذ اي قرارات في اجتماع
البيت الابيض وان القضيه يتوقع ان تناقشا
في الاسابيع القليله المقبله بحضور الرئيس
جوبيدا
[موسيقى]
اعتقلت تجهزه الامن في الشرطه في في رئيس
الجمهوريه بيدروكا ووصفته في تغريده على
تويتر بالرئيس السابق للبلاد بينما اعلنا
التلفزيون الرسميه ان رئيسه الوزراء بيكسي
شافيز اعلنت استقالتها وجاء ذلك بعد اعلان
كاستيا وحل البرلمان الذي تهيمن عليه
المعارضه اليمنيه التي صوتت لاحقا على
عزله بتهمه العجز الاخلاقي
واتجاهلت قراراته بحل البرلمان
في البلاد وقد سرع انصار الرئيس اليسرى
كاسيو والتظاهر امام الحرمان بعد التصويت
على اصله
انا
مسعود حسان كيف وصلنا الى هذه النقطه التي
يعزل فيها رئيس الجمهوريه بل يتحدث عن
القاء القبض عليه
الصور التي تظهر الرئيس البيروفي بيدرو
كاستيو وهو محتجز في مقر البلديه في
العاصمه ليما وذلك بعد اعتقاله من قبل
الشرطه عقب اعلانه لحاله الطوارئ وعزله
همم حله البرلمان البيروفي وذلك في اطار
الازمه السياسيه الكبيره التي كانت تعيشها
البيرو منذ ما قبل وصول البدروكسي وفي
يوليو عام 2021 الى الحكم واستمرت هذه
الازمه حتى هذه اللحظه التي وصلنا اليها
اليوم
بعزل الرئيس من قبل البرلمان
البيروفي هذا البرلمان ذاته الذي كان
الرئيس بيدرو كاسيو قد قام بحله ظهر هذا
اليوم قام بعزله باغلبيه وصوت من اصل 130
صوتا واتى هذا العزل بعد ايضا رفض
القرارات من قبل همم مختلف المسؤولين في
البلاد هذه القرارات التي كان قد اطلقها
الرئيس البيروفي المعزول الان والمحتجز من
قبل الشرطه البيروفيه التي كانت تشمل حل
البرلمان فرض حاله الطوارئ وفرض حظر
للتجول بالاضافه الى اعلان حكومه طارئه
واستثنائيه ايضا اتى هذا العزل في اطار
ايضا همم عدم قبول نائبه الرئيس ايضا بهذا
القرار وهمم هذه النائبه نائبه الرئيس همم
من المفترض ان يتم اعلانها ايضا رئيسا
للبلاد تكون اول رئيسه امراه ل- البيرو
همم في تاريخ الديمقراطيه همم البيروفيه
وهي متجهه نحو البرلمان
لتقوم باداء القسم واا ممارسه مهامها
كرئيس انتقاليه بعد عزل الرئيس كاستيو
طبعا هذا العزل اتى بناء على توهم همم
بعدم الاهليه الاخلاقيه وفق ما وصفتها همم
بدايه همم
المعارضه في البرلمان ثم الان المقصود
النيابه العامه بالقيام
ما المقصود بذلك
هذه هذه التهمه طبعا هي تشير لي الفساد
بشكل عام عاده ولكنه همم عندما لا يكون
هناك معلومات تدين الرئيس بشكل واضح تكون
هذه التهمه الفضفضه الى حد ما الى ان يتم
اثبات هذه التهم على الرئيس همم اذا
الاهليه الاخلاقيه مرتبطه بالفساد وكان
همم كانت النيابه العامه قد وجهت همم صباح
هذا اليوم توهما بالفساد للرئيس همم
البيروفي بادرو كاسيو على هذا الاساس كان
سيتم محاكمه الرئيس ومعرفه ما اذا كان همم
بالفعل هو متهم بهذه الدنيا او ممارسه لاي
من ممارسات الفساد املاح
استنى مسعود بنسوي باولو شكرا جزيلا لك
وهذه هي الاخبار عن ااا القاء اجهزه
الشرطه البيروفيه القبضه على الرئيس بيدرو
شامل شكرا
يعني طلاب الجامعه اللبنانيه الرسميه في
بيروت من عدم قدرتهم على تامين بدلات
النقل من اماكن اقامتهم الى الجامعه وذلك
بسبب ارتفاع تكلفتها
وشهدت موازنه الجامعه اللبنانيه تراجعا
حادا من 250 و65 مليون دولار عام 2018 الى
25 مليون دولار فقط هذا العام 80% منها
مخصصه للرواتب والاجور
هي الرحله الاولى لخالد في بدايه دراسته
الجامعيه
لكن الوصول الى كليه العلوم في الجامعه
اللبنانيه الرسميه ليس بالمهمه السهله
ذلك ان انتقاله من شمال لبنان الى بيروت
سيكلفه شهريا نصف راتب والده سكن في
اهلي فيني اعطوني المصاري الي عم تكلفه
يوم يومين بس ما فيني كافي اكيد هذا الشيء
تامين تكاليف الوصول الى الجامعه هو تحدي
بالنسبه الى خالد وزملائه ليس وحدهم من
يعانون
يكابدون بتامين كلفه الانتقال
وزياده ثلاثه اضعاف الراتب التي ستمنحها
الحكومه للاساتذه لن تكفيهم بعد تراجع
مدخولهم خلال السنوات الثلاث الماضيه
بثلاثه الاف الى نحو 300 دولار جر انهيار
صرف العمله الوطنيه
ورجعنا مع انه ما اخذنا شيء انتبهتوا علي
كيف ليه لان هو لي ولادنا اورايد بس
بالنهايه لا سمح الله انا اذا صار لي شيء
يمكن ما قادره اطبل بعد شوي انا ماشي يمكن
ما يؤديني بدل نقل
العدد الاكبر من طلاب لبنان
وتتوزع فروعها على مختلف المناطق لكن
الازمه الاقتصاديه ادت الى تراجع كبير في
موازنتها التي تؤمنها الحكومه اللبنانيه
وهو ما يشكل مخاطره تتهدد المستقبل
التعليميه لطلابها كلمه
ونحصل الاموال اللي وعدت الدوله
من ناحيه التسهيلات والتامين الحاجات
بيبقى عنا اهم لازم نحاول نعالجه له علاقه
بتحسين رواتب الاساسي
استمرار دون اضرابات او تعطيل قصري تقول
اداره الجامعه انها تعمل على قاعده
المعالجه وفق ما هو متاح لتطويق الازمات
التي قد يسببها اي تدهور اضافي للعمله
الوطنيه
يعتقد كثيرون من اساتذه وطلاب ان الجامعه
تعمل وسط ازمه ماليه لم تشهدها من قبل وان
اي تفاقم من جديد لها قد يعطل العام
الدراسي وقدره الجامعه على تامين الكهرباء
وتشغيل وصيانتي مبانيها ايهاب العقد
الجزيره بيروت
[موسيقى]
نعود من جديد لتونس وازمه الخبز الجديده
فيها حيث يقال عاده ان هذه الماده الحيويه
خط احمر لا ينبغي الا يتخطاه اي نظام اذن
تونس تعيش منذ شهور ازمه خانقه تزداد سوء
كل يوم وبين مطالب اصحاب المخابز وعجز
السلطات يعني
تبدو حرب الخبز مستمر
من المخابز التي دخلت في اضراب تستفيد من
عمليات دعم الخبز من الحكومه
الدفع وراء الحركه الاحتجاجيه هو تاخر
الدوله عن تسديد الديون المستحقه لاصحاب
المخابز التي تتجاوز حاليا 85 مليون دولار
قيمته دعم الخبز في تونس تبلغ نحو مئه
وخمسين مليون دولار دخول صندوق العام
للتعويض هو صندوق تخصصه الدوله
بثلاثه ملايين دولار حموله قارب تبلغ
قيمتها الاصليه 10 ملايين دولار لتعوض
الدوله الملايين السبعه الباقيه مع ما
ترتب على تاخر القارب في المواد
اكثروا ما يخشع التونسيون هو تكرار
سيناريو عام 84 حينما شهدت البلاد مظاهره
عنيفه بعد الزياده سعر الخبز سببت حين في
مقتل 100 شخص
ازمه الخبز في تونس وجه واحد فقط من اوجه
ازمه اقتصاديه وماليه خانقه تتفاقمه منذ
عقد من الزمن وتزداد معاناه البلاد في
المده الاخيره من نقص المواد الاساسيه
المستورده من الخارج بسبب بدايات حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا
تاتي هذه التطورات فيما تشهد العلاقه بين
الحكومه والاتحاد التونسي العام للشغل
تدهورا لسيما بعد حديث حكومه نجلاء بودن
عن رفع الدعم استجابه لمطالب صندوق النقد
الدولي بالقيام باصلاحات يعتبرها ضروريه
في مقابل تونس على قرض تمويل بقيمه مليار
و900 مليون دولار
الاتحاد الشغل يرفض الخضوع على شرطي لشروط
الصندوق النقد الدوليه لكن تونس تحتاجه
للقرض من اجل تسديد بعض الديون
واستراد بعض المواد المنعادمه في السوق
الولايات المتحده اعلنت في اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي تقديمها 60 مليون دولار
مساعده عاجله في تونس لاعانه الحالات
الاشد فقرا من تونس
في كليه الاقتصاد بجامعه قرطاج هو صحيح ان
اصحاب المخابز علقوا اضرابهم لكن نحن
نتحدث عن ازمه معقده لها يعني اشكال
وتجليات كثيره
ما مستقبل هذه الازمه ازمه الخبز
اولا شكرا على الصداقه
همم صحيح تم اعلاق همم او تعليق الاضرار
او لنقل تم ترحيله الى همم 10 جانفي
وهذا همم
يبين بانه الاشكال لازقه
والاشكال المرتبط اساسا بعدم ايفاء
الحكومه بتعاهدتها لانه هذا الاضرار هو
الثاني في اقل من ثلاثه اشهر نتذكر بانه
كان هناك اضراب في اكتوبر والحكومه همم
قدمت تعهدات ولكن في نهايه المطاف بهذه
التعاودات
نعم اليوم نفس الاشكال يطرح
الحكومه
واصحاب المخابز يدخلون في اضراب ولكن يبدو
بان
الاشكال ذاهب الى الحل ولكن في اعتقادي
الحل دائما هو حل يعني وقتي وليس حل جذري
لانه لو لو نعود الى اشكاليات او الى ازمه
الخبز اساس ان هي تتعلق بثلاثه مشاكل
رئيسيه اولا همم ضعف مخزون الحبوب وعن
الحكومه ان تعمل جاهدا لي تطوير او تقويه
مخزون الحبوب ثانيا هناك ضغط الاسعار وهذا
مرتبط اساسا
الاسواق العالميه والحكومه المطالبه
بتقديم حلول خاصه
اننا نتحدث عن ازمات معقده قد يقول قائل
انها اكبر من اي حكومه هل هنالك يمكن ان
تفعله الحكومه التونسيه لحل هذه الازمات
المتراكبه منذ عشر عشر سنوات او ربما اكثر
سواء سواء الخبز او الحليب او السكر كل
الازمات مرتبطه اساسا
بالعوامل الداخليه والخارجيه وهناك العديد
والعديد من الحلول الحكومه الحكومه التربت
همم النقص في المواد الاساسيه في همم
المشاكل الموجوده في سلسله الامدادات
العالميه
وتعتبر بانه هناك مشاكل في الاحتكار صحيح
هناك مشاكل في الاحتكار هناك مشاكل على
السوق العالميه ولكن هناك حلول يمكن
تقديمها حلول على مستوى تقويه همم التخزين
في تونس خاصه من المواد الاستراتيجيه
الاهم من هذا كل ايفاء الدوله بتعاهداتها
لكي لا يتكرر همم هذا النوع من من الضربات
او لا تتكرر هذا النوع من الازمات ثم همم
هناك اصلاحات يجب ان تقوم بها ان الدوله
خاصه اص منظومه الدعم لانه سمعنا كثيرا
بتوجيه الدعم الى مستحقيه ولكن لحد هذه
اللحظه لم يتم ولم يتم توجيه الدعم
لمستحقين طالما لم تكن هناك رؤيه متكامله
رؤيه شامله اين يتم تحديد الخيارات
الاستراتيجيه اين يتم اااه تحضير المعرفه
الاجتماعي
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا
موعدنا مع موجز لاهم الانباء قبل الانتقال
الى الجوله الرياضيه يوميات المونديال
اعتقلت السلطات الالمانيه 25 شخصا بينهم
جنود سابقون ينتمون الى جماعه من اقصى
اليمين بتهمه الاعداد لاسقاط الدوله وقالت
الحكومه ان المجموعه كانت تنوي لاستلاء
على السلطه بالقوه وانشاء جيش موازن
وتنفيذ هجمات داخل المانيا
على قائد ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
مظلوم عبدي رفضه المقترح الروسيه القاضيه
بتسليم المناطق الحدوديه مع تركيا الى
قوات النظام السوري لتجنيب المنطقه عمليه
عسكريه
قالت مصادر تركيا الجزيره
ان بلاده مهتمه بعمليه استئناف الحوار بين
تركيا وسوريا على اساس اتفاقي اضنه الذي
يمنح انقره حق التدخل في سوريا لحمايه
امنها
اعلنت قوه المهام المشتركه التابعه لتحالف
الدولي التزام التحالف في بدعم من وصفهم
بشركائه فيما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
وسكان الشمالي شرقي سوريا وفي واشنطن قال
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي
ان الولايات المتحده لا تريد حدوث اي
عمليات عسكريه في شمال سوريا
حمل الرئيس الروسي الذيمر بوتين اوكرانيا
مسؤوليه نشوب الحرب وقال انه لم تتح اي
فرصه لتسويه الازمه واضاف بوتين ان
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه تفي اوكرانيا قد
تتحولوا الى عمليه طويله لمد
ومن جانب اخر قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال
الاطلسي ان فرص السلامي في اوكرانيا باتت
منعدمه حاليا كما قال وزير الخارجيه
على دعم الجيش الاوكراني بكل ما يحتاجه
للدفاع عن بلازا لكنها لا تشجع اوكرانيا
على تنفيذ ضربات داخل الاراضي الروسيه
ايات الحصاد شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه في
امان الله
[موسيقى]